welcome back to the stronger by science
podcast my name is eric trexler i am the
special
temporary primary host of the show today
i am joined by a special guest he is
currently the permanent co-host uh the
guest co-host i should say of the show
his name is greg knuckles uh we have a
lot of great content uh for today's
episode but before we get into that
it is with great shame and humility that
we beg for your support
and i'd like to present a number of ways
you could provide that you could
like rate or subscribe to the show
wherever you happen to get podcasts you
could go to strongerbyscience.com
newsletter and join our newsletter email
list
you could uh go to strongerbyscience.com
coaching and check out our very talented
very experienced team of coaches for
one-on-one virtual coaching services
you could use our discount code at
bulksupplements.com if you use the code
sbs pod that gets you five percent off
of your order you can check out the mass
research review which we publish every
single month reviewing important new
studies in exercise in nutrition or you
can check out macro factor our diet app
which does have a free trial so you can
take it for a spin and see if you like
it uh greg road to the stage how are
things going yeah things are going
pretty well uh no new milestones this
week nothing uh
super exciting to report at least in
terms of numbers on the scale
but overall things are still trending in
a good trajectory uh as i guess like a
bit of more of a dietary update than
anything um
i'm i'm trying a fun little experiment
um and by experiment i mean i got i got
tired of meal prepping and uh
actually investing time and effort into
doing that
so uh what i'm doing with my diet now is
is basically the same macros as before
but replacing all of the things that
actually took effort to prepare with
just fruit so now i'm just cooking up a
big pan of chicken thighs and that is
all of my protein and fat
and
yeah some from like milk as well for my
tea and coffee uh but pretty much just
just chicken like seasoned chicken
thighs and that's that and then all of
my carbs are coming from fruit um
which is great uh i love fruit and uh
yeah i i
had previously been you know taking time
and effort
to
make good meals with the macro splits i
want uh trying to get veggies in and
whatnot
and uh yeah that that takes time and
effort when instead i could just get a
huge bowl of strawberries or eat like 10
kiwis in a sitting um
so that's much easier and quite frankly
much more delicious fruit is incredible
um
and so
uh
one very important thing to note about
this little experiment
is
any relation uh to how paul saladino
currently eats
is purely coincidental i didn't find out
about this until i mentioned that i was
going to start doing this in the macro
factor facebook group someone was like
oh is that because that's how paul
saladino eats
and that almost made me not want to do
this
because i didn't want anyone to make
that mistake purely coincidental
my reasoning for it and his completely
different
he is afraid that all other plants
besides fruit are trying to kill him and
he's terrified of that
i just like eating fruit um
so yeah yeah he's really big on the idea
of plant defense chemicals yeah um which
is very funny because those that's why
plants are good for you
it's also why they're delicious yeah um
i mean i love a good spicy meal i love a
nice caffeinated beverage yeah that so
i'm glad that you clarified that because
that's going to make my life a lot
easier fielding questions
um awesome so on the road to athens um
the road to athens just because of my uh
lingering hip issue
which frustratingly
i was like okay hip hurts too much to do
a lot of the lifting that i like maybe
i'll try uh marathon running didn't
really work out for that either
uh so the road to athens has basically
become
the way i train to maintain some
semblance of endurance and strength
until i i have rehab to the point where
i can really effectively take uh
structured endurance running head on
again
and i'm very optimistic about that it's
not like i'm saying oh that's that's
never gonna happen
um but yeah for now i'm just finding
ways to exercise that uh allow me to
continue making some form of fitness
progress without exacerbating any
symptoms uh with my hip
so um yeah a couple developments lately
i finally am like getting my skill set
back for basketball i mentioned the
other day uh i'm finally getting to a
point where
depending on the pickup game that
materializes uh at first like i hadn't
touched a basketball in 15 years i
didn't belong on the court it was a mess
but i'm finally getting to that point
where i feel like i can really hold my
own
uh
in the type of pickup game that i would
like to play so that's been fun it just
makes the cardio way more enjoyable when
you're like yes i'm a contributing
member of my team who's very very
valuable to our endeavor yeah so that
was fun and then i finally got out on
the paddle board for the first session
uh of the year i kept waiting for it to
warm up and then the moment it got warm
enough i was super busy and just
couldn't carve out the time for it but
this weekend got out on the water did
some stand up paddle boarding it is a
really really fun and enjoyable way to
do some leisurely cardio uh you know
i'm sure that once you get pretty
skilled with it you can get the heart
rate up a little bit for me i'm just
kind of paddling around having fun
enjoying the sun the fresh air uh you
know the uh the social aspect of doing
it with my girlfriend and things like
that
but yeah stand-up paddle boarding is
it's not super accessible i recognize
that there's some cost involved you also
have to be near a suitable body of water
uh but if you have the opportunity to uh
to give it a shot it's a lot of fun and
very easy to pick up like you know you
might look at it and say like i don't
know if i have the balance for it um
you pick it up pretty quickly good deal
yeah all right so feats of strength what
do you got
yeah so i i've got one from the
weightlifting world this week uh so the
european weightlifting championships
were this past weekend
and antonino pizzolatto who is a
italian weightlifter
he set a new world record for both the
clean and jerk and the total in the 89
kilo class uh and the the cleaning jerk
was 217 kilos so for our american
listeners that's
478 pounds at a body weight of 196.
and uh the the video will be linked in
the show notes if you want to check it
out and i gotta say it looked about as
easy as one could expect a world record
clean and jerk to look um
so
he uh
uh
antonino pizolato has recently moved up
in weight classes he previously competed
at 81 and 85. he's moved up to the 89s
uh immediately set the world record and
he really looks like he's coming into
his own in this class like it it looks
like it it suits him really well uh in
the european championships he set 11
kilo prs for both the snatch and clean
and jerk 22 kilo pr total um so yeah
this seems to be a class that that fits
him really well and since he just
recently moved up i would anticipate
that that he breaks his own record again
uh pretty soon so congrats to him all
right good stuff
um now moving on to the
the content for today's episode the
first thing that we want to do
is revisit a conversation from last
episode so i was presenting
a little segment about some buffering
supplements and we took a little detour
and talked about the role of acidosis or
this accumulation
of excess protons and how that directly
might impact the progression or
development of muscular fatigue during
high intensity exercise
and we kind of reached a bit of an you
know we reached a bit of an impasse
where i said let's hit the books let's
go take a look at some research and
revisit this topic uh rather than kind
of speculate our way through it and try
to make sense of it but
the route um
just to kind of summarize
where we
got with that conversation that there's
an interesting
uh challenge with interpreting this
literature because there are different
types of buffering strategies that have
been tested uh within the context of
various types of sprint work or
resistance training so those buffering
strategies would include beta alanine
supplementation
as an extension of that i think you
could lump in
anserine and carnosine supplementation
sodium bicarbonate supplementation which
is an extracellular rather than
intracellular buffer and also just good
old-fashioned hyperventilation which is
certainly not supplementation at all
just breathing
in a particular pattern so what's
interesting about these three different
buffering strategies is theoretically
you could suggest that maybe they could
impact fatigue through some other
mechanism that's not directly related to
buffering
but all three seem to work to some
extent in the right context with high
intensity exercise and certainly the
most parsimonious explanation would be
that they are working through the
mechanism that they all share which is
buffering these excess protons delaying
drops in ph and delaying
acidosis to some extent
theoretically delaying fatigue
so that's all very cohesive and
straightforward but the challenge is
that you know back in the day when we
were
well i the tide turned slowly in
research
there's a difference between when
research started getting published and
when people started becoming aware of it
right i was gonna say like when i was an
undergrad it was a very straightforward
narrative right like acidosis
contributes to fatigue it alters the way
muscle fibers work it alters their
contractile function in a variety of
different ways that was kind of the
undergrad level pretty simple
explanation but already at that time
there were papers trickling out that
were saying
i don't know if that's necessarily true
um and the root of this um confusion
comes from you know there were
absolutely some early studies that made
it seem without question
that acidosis had a direct role
and not just direct but a primary role
in inducing and
you know
driving the progression of fatigue
during high intensity exercise so there
were really two kinds of research
driving this idea first was just a
really simple correlation that obviously
is observed very routinely
we're doing exercise that produces
acidosis and of course as that acidosis
gets more and more intense we we notice
that fatigue gets more and more um
noteworthy so there's this kind of clear
correlation that as acidosis goes up and
ph drops we see a clear onset and
progression of fatigue so just at the
surface level that certainly drove this
perspective and then there was also very
mechanistic in vitro work where they
would expose
uh isolated fibers to these low ph baths
and they would notice that a variety of
different aspects of contractile
function would get impaired from these
these low ph very acidic baths so you
can absolutely find papers and i'll link
a couple in the show notes where they go
through all the different contractile
processes and metabolic processes that
can get messed up by bathing a muscle
fiber in an acidic solution so things
that relate to calcium sensitivity force
production
sarcoplasmic reticulum handling of
calcium
you know different energetic processes
involved in excitation contraction
coupling and the crossbridge cycle
i'll link those in the show notes for
anyone who wants to dig through them but
but there is this mechanistic basis
where you would say yes low ph uh
prevalence of you know a really acidic
or the presence i should say of a really
acidic environment this drives fatigue
at the muscle fiber level
the challenge there is that people
started to look into this a little bit
deeper
and they noticed that the experimental
conditions were not matching
physiological conditions so
most notably the phs that were getting
tested were often a little bit lower
than physiological levels you would
anticipate so it was an exaggerated
effect of acidosis
and also something that i didn't quite
expect
temperature appears to be an important
issue a lot of these studies were just
taking place in ambient temperature
but of course the intramuscular
temperature during high intensity
exercise all the heat that's being
generated secondary to contraction and
metabolism
you know they were noticing that these
experiments are not being performed at
physiological temperatures that are
compatible with intense exercise
and when they started doing those
studies those mechanistic kind of single
fiber studies where they say well let's
do it at a temperature that mimics high
intensity exercise and let's do it at a
ph
that mimics high intensity exercise all
of a sudden this really disastrous
impact of acidosis and low ph
was not impacting muscle function the
way that it previously had been shown to
and so that's where the field just kind
of started saying well that's
uncomfortable right so yeah we kind of
reached that point in the episode last
week where we said okay
that is something that we cannot ignore
but it's also very odd that these
buffering strategies seem to work you
know if acidosis isn't driving fatigue
why are they working and so at first i
thought maybe we were missing something
obvious but i was really relieved to
look at some of the more recent review
papers
and a lot of them point out the same
thing they say okay so
we can't really pin this all on low ph
but all these buffers
you know several different types of
buffers that work somewhat independently
they all seem to work and that's weird
yeah so so there's definitely something
going on here and that's kind of where
we left it in this episode i want to
propose two areas that might give us
some additional clarification two
different lines of research that might
help us make sense of this so
uh first of all uh there's one line of
research that is looking at you know
creating force and power with muscles we
talk about it being a neuromuscular
process right so of course the muscle
fibers themselves are doing things
that's where a lot of this acidosis
research lives is looking at individual
fibers but we can't forget that the the
neuromuscular system involves these
neural inputs uh that are really
critical to actually making muscles work
right and so uh that involves the nerves
that send messages down to the muscle to
contract but also the nervous system is
responsible for
gathering information you know from the
periphery and relaying that to more
central structures that dictate some of
those outgoing neural messages for
contraction
so i am going to link a paper in the
show notes that focuses specifically on
what they call
metabonociceptors which uh respond to
things like high lactate high atp levels
excess protons or or you know the
development of acidosis
there are these uh afferent
uh
signals basically that come back into
the the nervous system uh particularly
during high intensity exercise where
there's a lot of lactate a lot of
protons and uh there is a reasonably
convincing amount of evidence suggesting
that it's very possible that when
muscles are doing this high intensity
activity and we are seeing this acidosis
developing the acidosis might not be you
know catastrophically impacting the
actual contractile function of the the
fiber itself but it might be sending
signals back to the nervous system that
the nervous system of course is
responding to saying hey
[ __ ] hurts down there uh things are
going pretty intense uh
we're making a lot of energy very
quickly which of course is a threatening
thing to any living organism so the idea
is that there is uh some some kind of
complex
uh communication going on
with these receptors and the nervous
system that is potentially contributing
to fatigue but from more neurally
mediated uh centers and the idea is that
the muscle fibers themselves can still
work in that ph but upstream there are
nervous uh you know nerve
signals from the nervous system telling
the muscle i know you can work but maybe
don't
like some some like central governor
hypothesis stuff yeah yeah so the the
idea is that uh the nervous system is
basically uh
decreasing some of that motor neuron
firing to reduce muscle output due to
fatigue that is being sensed at the
central level in response to peripheral
metabolite accumulation
that that's the one area that uh that i
think
might help us understand what might be
going on here so it's a lot more complex
than just putting a muscle fiber in a
bath yeah
that's basically what i threw out is
just a wild guess before we started yeah
yeah that is true
um
now that's like i said there's two lines
of research i find really interesting
that's one of them i think it's very
compelling if i had to put my money on
one i'd say that probably explains most
of the confusion involved with acidosis
fatigue and buffers as ergogenic
ingredients there is also some research
that i'll put in the show notes where um
they specifically were looking at the
independent effect this was back to very
mechanistic in vitro stuff uh with you
know with isolated fibers
so what they were looking at is the
independent effect of elevated ph
or i'm sorry elevated proton
concentration or reduced ph acidosis
basically they were looking at the
independent effect of acidosis the
independent effect of inorganic
phosphate accumulation which you
mentioned last episode
and then the combined effect of the two
of them at varying temperature levels
and in varying
muscle fiber types
and of course as you can
gather from that explanation of the
study the results very
nitty gritty hard science stuff going on
here but the very simplified uh result
kind of summary is that the collective
that the combined effect
of having low ph and a lot of inorganic
phosphate had a much bigger effect on
force and power output of the muscle
fiber than either aspect individually
and that effect was most pronounced at
lower temperatures but still persisted
at temperatures that replicate
physiological exercise like temperatures
it was exaggerated in type 2 fibers more
so than type 1 fibers
and like i said that combined effect was
much larger than the independent effect
of either one there seems to be some
degree of synergy there so i think
inorganic phosphate definitely still if
i had to put my finger on
one metabolite that is likely to be
directly driving fatigue i would still
put it on inorganic phosphate but it
does seem like there is a synergistic
relationship by which
the acidosis that develops during
fatigue and high intensity exercise that
is kind of working with inorganic
phosphate to produce this
progression of fatigue during high
intensity exercise so um it looks like
you know you could look at the more
uh neural route and get some
explanations you can look at some of
these more sophisticated updated in
vitro studies that have built upon some
of these revelations related to acidosis
and temperature um
there is a narrative that is coming
together and and you can start to see
some of the aspects
of how we will eventually understand
fatigue progression
during
very high intensity glycolytic exercise
there's enough here to say i think we're
starting to notice the main characters
of the story a little bit uh but there's
still some work to do to put together
the relative contributions of how this
all fits together
but at the very least i i don't think
we're in a position where we say
buffers work but it makes no sense at
all why yeah but i think we are at a
position where we say buffers work
but it's a hell of a lot more
complicated than just saying if you can
keep you know buffering protons a little
better you know fatigue will be
uh delayed in perpetuity there's a
there's a lot more that seems to be
going on here with fatigue it looks like
buffering some of those protons can be
helpful but the story with muscle
fatigue is very very complicated uh and
there's a lot of moving parts there so
hopefully this provides a little bit of
clarity related to our previous segment
and hopefully
my god i hope
this is just one additional little
anecdote that leads you to be a little
more skeptical of content creators who
just
take a mechanism and run with it yeah
and just kind of speculate and speculate
and speculate based on mechanisms
because
you can only speculate on a mechanism
that and and derive actionable
kind of practical takeaways
if you assume that we already know
everything about the processes involved
and that there will be absolutely no
downstream effects you haven't accounted
for and no other moving pieces that you
haven't accounted for so
we've talked in past shows about
you know where we fit on the spectrum
between you know how much you rely on
mechanisms in theory how much you rely
on empirical data i think we both tend
to rely a lot on empirical data whenever
it's available
because this is just one additional
instance where
stuff gets complicated in the body and
there are a lot of processes where there
are
overlapping mechanisms and redundant
mechanisms and synergistic mechanisms
and most notably mechanisms that we
don't know about yet yeah uh and so
trying to take mechanisms and just say
oh yeah i i have a perfect uh
series of strategies to exploit that it
it it can be done sometimes but it gets
messy yeah yeah i i do think that
there's a general tendency
for
people
i was going to say people outside of
science but even people in science to
overestimate how much we already know
about the body and how it works
when like
i don't know like i i do
i i think that that largely relates to
like maybe people looking at the history
of science and medicine in particular
and looking at the rate of progress that
we made on stuff from you know basically
like maybe the inter war period until
the 70s
and it seems like the rate of progress
is slowing down a little bit and so i
think then the natural implication is
like oh well you know maybe we've we've
basically learned the vast majority of
what there is to know about the body and
so like
uh
you know if someone's
talking about mechanisms they're talking
about a variable in a solved problem um
when like that that really just isn't
the case like i think one of the best
examples of that
was
like not even that long ago maybe like
2014 2015 uh
scientists discovered the lymphatic
system in the central nervous system uh
now turned the glymphatic system
and like
it's a shitload of lymphatic tissue and
uh they just hadn't found it before
yeah and so like that
that completely uh
like revolutionizes our understanding of
how things can flow into and out of the
brain and what might be able to affect
the central nervous system that that we
were unaware of before it's like
truly revolutionary finding uh
and yeah like we were just like
completely in the dark about it until
like seven years ago
so yeah and and that's you know that's
like macro scale stuff that's stuff you
can learn via dissection in terms of
what's go like every little thing that's
going on in each muscle fiber like no
we're we're still
we we certainly know
the way science progresses like we know
more this year than last year we know
more now we know a lot more now than we
did 10 years ago and we certainly know a
lot more than a hundred years ago
but uh yeah there's there's still so
much left to learn
yeah no it's it's true i mean uh
is something that can be very humbling
is when you study exercise science and
then
someone asks you a question that like
they assume like
surely you guys have worked that out to
a very clear understanding and a
universal consensus
yeah but you start getting questions
about stuff and we're not talking about
like
you know
questions that are just you know
very elaborate specific unique
circumstances it's just like hey what's
up with cramps yeah well i mean my go-to
is just like
what's the best way to train in a
calorie deficit like should i keep the
volume high or keep the intensity high
people don't believe me when i tell them
this there's no research on that yeah
like there are there aren't any like
direct rcts comparing one approach
versus the other which is crazy because
that that is like just a very basic
thing
and yeah it's not that it's not that
there are some studies that could be
better there's just not research on it
yeah yeah and then there's there's other
areas you know like i said where there's
research but there's still like you know
competing theories that have not been
stifled and you know there hasn't been
like a very very universal scientific
consensus and like
we're talking about research right now
on fatigue
you would think that like with exercise
you're like what's one of the first
things that we should sort out that that
is where our whole field started correct
yeah that's like
the harvard fatigue yeah yeah that's
because because the the whole point of
exercise science initially was just how
can we make soldiers better uh like you
know because military funding
was was that during the inter war years
or was that post world war ii but it
whatever it doesn't matter but like that
was the whole point like you know we
want our soldiers to be able to go
longer and fatigue less on the
battlefield than the people were
fighting against so like the army well
the military just gave a ton of money to
harvard and they're like figure out how
fatigue works uh because you know we
think that will give us an advantage in
war so like
that that is where
that's where our entire field started
yeah and yeah we don't we don't even
have a full picture of fatigue yet right
yeah it's crazy
um all right so hopefully that cleared
some things up and made people far less
confident in everything they've ever
thought about the things they do
so
next up you've got a couple segments uh
i think it's probably best to let you
intro them yourself yeah so i've got uh
first one i've got an article discussion
segment uh so
we recently published an article titled
where are all of the female participants
in strength hypertrophy and supplement
research uh this was a
uh
what are we calling them again
what's the what's the name for this type
of article a cover story a cover story
yeah yeah so uh we're we're starting
something new with mass where we publish
a cover story each month um
you know just kind of like uh
like when you go to a
grocery store and you see the magazines
on the stands uh and you know it's a
it's a magazine has a ton of content in
it but they're going to lead with a
cover story to kind of draw you in
entice you to check it out um so we're
we're gonna start going that route with
mass and we're gonna be publishing the
cover stories on stronger by science uh
so you know be on the lookout for that
the first of each month
and our first cover story uh was was won
by yours truly
and uh
yeah so i
was interested
uh primarily in
the extent to which female subjects are
understudied and underrepresented in
the sorts of research
that the stronger by science article or
the stronger by science audience cares
about so
you know strength research hypertrophy
research body comp research supplement
research
mostly related to resistance training
and
this was
so
part of the problem was that there have
been
prior attempts to quantify
male versus female research
participation in exercise science
generally so the title of my article was
actually an homage to a 2014 study by
costello and colleagues that was that
was looking at this question
um
but again it was just looking at just
kind of exercise science generally so uh
what costello and colleagues did
is they looked at all of the research
published in three of the major journals
in our field uh medicine and science and
sport and exercise british journal of
sports medicine an american journal of
sports medicine for a three-year period
so from 2011 to 2013
uh and you know just pulling up each
like all of the articles published in
those three journals for for that three
year span and just counting up like how
many total male subjects were there in
all of these articles how many total
female subjects were there in all of
these articles
and what they found
was that the total subject pool was
about uh 39 female and 61 male
but that is of limited utility for us uh
primarily
primarily because there's a ton of
research in our field that is not at all
related to resistance training so
like those journals are going to have a
lot of stuff about rehab they're going
to have a lot of stuff about injuries
they're going to have a lot of stuff
about aerobic training they have a lot
of stuff
about just like kind of general public
healthy type research what a waste
i mean it's it's good stuff but it's
it's not like directly relevant it won't
make you stronger correct which is a
waste exactly um
and so you know basically it found there
was about a 60 40 split
and
my hunch was that that wasn't quite
right for resistance training related
research uh like something we've noticed
when writing
uh mass articles in the past
is we'll stumble into an area of
research that has like 15 studies that
are just all on men or there's like you
know 12 studies on men and one on women
and so i was always thinking like uh 60
40
like
would be would be nice but i think it's
it's worse than that for resistance
training research
and one of the other things that put me
further down that road
is there was an article published in
science news by a
journalist who also happens to have a
phd in physiology and pharmacology named
bethany brookshire who
basically took a really similar approach
to costello and colleagues but
instead of just simply giving the
numbers
she broke it down by research area
and so what she found is that when you
kind of categorize by types of research
so you know splitting things out into
metabolism-based research disease-based
research basic physiology research uh
research looking into the social aspects
of ex of exercise research looking at
sports injury and research looking
specifically at performance so when you
split things out like that
research related to everything but
performance seems to have a
something approaching an equitable split
so anything from
40 percent female 60 male to 60 percent
female 40 male like things are looking
pretty good
and then for the performance studies in
particular
uh there there was one study that had 90
000 subjects looking at marathon pacing
strategy that had a fair number of
female subjects in it but that was also
the majority of the total subjects in in
those performance related studies so uh
when you just exclude that one
uh
that one study that kind of had undue
weight on the analysis uh the
performance related studies uh in in the
journals that she looked at only three
percent of the subjects were female
which uh
that seemed too low to me based on the
research i'd been reading but
it at least gave me a further inkling
that at least for the research that
we're the most interested in
uh there's probably fewer than than
approximately 40 female subjects uh so
yeah i wanted to look into that
and i wasn't interested in
just characterizing
the ratios of male and female subjects
in the research we care about i also
wanted to see how trends were shifting
over time so
you know
is it a scenario where there were way
more male than female subjects in the
research in say the 90s and 2000s but
it's it's trending towards being more
equitable now or
the other direction um
and i also
wanted to
get get a rough idea of
the degree to which this matters so
um i i think it
i'll i'll talk about that with a bit
more nuance later but uh essentially you
know if
if there is a scenario where
female lifters are quite
underrepresented in the research now i
wanted to get a decent idea of well okay
given that
set of circumstances
um
how confident can we be in generalizing
research on male subjects to female
populations and also vice versa and and
this is something that comes up a lot as
someone who talks about science on the
internet uh if i share a study where all
of the subjects are male
i'll generally get a comment or two from
women very understandably so being like
hey all of these subjects are male i
don't know if this research will apply
to me or generalized to me
and
vice versa but much more extreme if we
share a study where the subjects are
female there will always be like half a
dozen angry dudes in the comments being
like the subjects are women like this
doesn't apply to me this is dumb why did
you share this and it gets uh
exponentially worse after menopause
correct i noticed that if you publish a
study on post-menopausal women those
comments go through the roof yeah for
sure um
which
th those annoy me more than anything
because like
it seems like the assumption is that
post-menopausal women basically don't
exist and so why should you talk about
them and it's like
i gotta tell you man half the population
are women
they will all become postmenopausal at
some point and there are post-menopausal
women in our audience so like
whatever deal with it uh so yeah i i was
interested in that as well
and so the
strategy i devised to attempt to tackle
this question
is to basically let meta analyses do a
lot of the heavy lifting for me so i
wanted to
find a representative sample of recent
systematic reviews and meta-analyses in
our field
and kind of mine them
for
characteristics of the studies that were
included in those systematic reviews and
meta-analyses because most uh most
review papers like that will have a
table generally it's table two
that just gives a rundown of what
studies were included in the systematic
reviewer meta-analysis uh you know what
were the subject characteristics how
many subjects were there
and so that that accomplishes
a couple purposes for me
one is i was writing this on a deadline
and uh you know basically i could look
at about 40 systematic reviews and
meta-analyses
and bring in data about
600 plus individual studies
whereas if i looked at all 600 of those
individual studies one by one coded them
myself it would have instead of being a
pretty intensive two-week process it
would have been a pretty intensive
two-month process which i simply didn't
have time for
and two
systematic reviews and meta-analyses do
start with a systematic literature
search and so i wanted to ensure that i
wasn't getting a biased sample of
research to base my analysis on and so
you know
other people were already doing unbiased
systematic searches so i felt pretty
good about leaning on them to to pull in
representative papers
um
so yeah i uh
i pulled in an initial pool of 45
systematic reviews and meta-analyses
there's a page on stronger by science
where we just kind of like keep a
running list of all of the relevant
systematic reviews and metas being
published in our field um and i just
kind of went down that and i tried to
find basically all of the recent ones on
things that we get asked about
pretty often
to get
to get a representative sample of the
research that that you guys care about
um and then from there i i you know just
looked into them extracted all of the
relevant information and uh and went on
with my analysis uh all of the details
about my specific methodology you can
find them in the article which which
will be linked in the show notes
uh so yeah let's uh let's get into the
results
so what i found uh is
uh dealing with a total sample of 628
unique studies um
65 of or 65 percent of them so 408 out
of the 268
used male only cohorts uh 133 or about
21 percent used mixed sex samples and uh
73 or only about
12 percent used female only cohorts
and 14 of the studies or about 2 percent
did not specify the sex of the subjects
they used in their study
in terms of
trends shifting over time
basically what i found is that from the
90s on
the proportion of studies that use mixed
sex cohorts has basically been flat it's
been about 20 percent of studies uh
every decade since since the 90s but
what i also found is that the proportion
of studies that use female only cohorts
has actually been going down and the
proportion of studies that use male-only
cohorts has been going up so
the relative rep
representation of female subjects in
this area of research
uh contrary to what i assumed uh is
actually getting worse over time which
uh
i didn't love seeing and then uh like i
mentioned i wanted to get a
rough idea
of
how generalizable research was between
uh studies on on male samples and uh
studies on female samples
and so
this this was a very quick and dirty way
to do this analysis but it was
really i think the only feasible way to
do it
so what i did is for all of the metas i
looked at that had forest plots what i
would do
is
look at the
effect estimates from studies with
female only cohorts and look to see if
the 95 confidence intervals of those
effect estimates overlapped with the 95
confidence interval of the pooled effect
estimate for
like the the full analysis
um
and so that that like i said is
is a quick and dirty way of looking at
it so you know if you have a wide
confidence interval you could have mean
effect estimates that differ quite a bit
while the confidence intervals still
overlap um
confidence intervals
overlapping doesn't necessarily mean
that two things aren't uh
uh significantly different in terms of
like statistical significance
um
and like the the ideal way to go about
doing this analysis would just be to
recreate
metas
for
for all of these things like for for
each one of
the metas that have been published
recode everything perform a
meta-analysis on the mail-only studies
perform a meta-analysis on the mixed sex
cohorts perform a meta-analysis on the
female-only studies and then compare
those pooled effect estimates um but
that would have involved doing 201
individual meta-analyses which i don't
have time for and quite quite frankly i
don't think anyone has time for i could
have just emailed the authors of the
original papers and done a participant
level meta-analysis with individual data
that that would have been even better
that that's what i would have done
personally but anyway go on but yeah so
so if i went that route we want to be
talking about
a one like a two week project or a two
month project or even a two year project
that that would be a career spanning
project
um
which yeah i just wasn't going to do but
yeah so so just looking to see if
confidence intervals overlap that's
again it's a very quick and dirty way to
assess this uh but what i found is that
of the 185 effect estimates from female
only studies across 67 forest plots
those confidence intervals overlapped
with the confidence intervals of the
pooled effect estimates
almost 95 of the time so 94.6 percent of
the time
which is
so you you can't take that as evidence
that
studies on male and female cohorts
get get the
exact same responses but that that is
reasonably strong evidence that the
at least like the responses aren't
night and day different most of the time
uh so you know you can't assume that
results will generalize perfectly but
your a priori assumption should be that
they the most of the time generalized
pretty well
so um so yeah that's what i found
and
just getting into
my takeaways from this at least
so the first one well i mean really my
biggest takeaway
is just that there should be a lot more
research that uses mixex samples
most of the time results in in male and
female subjects aren't that different so
using a mixex cohort has a couple
advantages one is it would simply make
recruitment a lot easier
you know if you're
now recruiting from the entire human
population instead of half of the human
population it should be easier to
recruit more subjects
a lot of the times recruitment is the
hardest part of doing research like
especially if you're doing a reasonably
large study recruitment can be like
pulling teeth uh so
you know
making recruitment easier and adjust
like in any way that is justifiable
will just make science work better and
two you know it will generally make more
results more generalizable and you can
have more confidence in the
generalizability of your results
which is also a good thing
one of the so
the biggest piece of criticism i've
gotten about this piece
that that i would like to address
because
uh
i was going to say in my opinion it's
not valid criticism but it's not just my
opinion this is completely invalid
criticism uh
there were people who would comment like
when we shared this on instagram or
facebook or wherever
be like well you know greg you're you're
a stupid idiot here uh
female subjects aren't being
underrepresented in the research uh the
only reason that there are fewer female
subjects than male subjects is you're
interested in resistance training
research
and there's just way more men than women
who are doing resistance training
and you know therefore
this is about what you should expect
and that's
that's a really dumb criticism
because
65 of these studies
used male-only cohorts and so what that
means is that being female
was an exclusion criterion which means
that if a woman wanted to
participate in those studies she [ __ ]
couldn't uh so if we lived in a world
where
all of this research used mixed sex
cohorts
and you still saw oh uh actually i
forgot to mention one of the most
important findings uh so just in so i
talked about the the breakdown of
individual studies in terms of just
total participants i found that 75 of
the subjects were male 25 were female so
big headline finding completely forgot
to mention anyway going back to what i
was talking about
um yeah so if we lived in a world where
all of these studies used mixed sex
cohorts and we saw that same breakdown
of participants they're all mixed sex uh
the researchers are trying to recruit
both males and females and they're still
getting 75 males 25 females then you
could say okay you know maybe the women
aren't being underrepresented and you're
just seeing a reflection of general
interest in resistance training and
by extension participating in research
related to resistance training
that's not the [ __ ] world we live in
uh
when
women can't participate in two-thirds of
the studies
you can't say
that they're not participating in these
studies because they don't want to
they're not participating in these
studies because they're not allowed to
participate in these studies
so
i just want to make that very clear
i
strongly suspect that
the people who were making those
comments saw the topic of the article
and uh
just immediately jumped to conclusions
if you actually read the article it
should be pretty clear why things are
the way they are uh but that argument
also kind of breaks down because it
seems like the argument is um
because
more men a higher proportion are already
engaged in resistance training they are
uh voluntarily participating in these
studies because
i mean a lot of studies are on people
who are explicitly untrained that is
also true
like if you train you cannot do this
study yes that that is true as well um
i mean
mo
yeah most of the studies are on
untrained people and most of the
subjects are undergrad and most of the
subjects participate either because
they're getting paid 20 bucks which is a
lot of money to an undergrad student or
they're getting like five points of
extra credit in a class and i'm pretty
sure women like extra credit just as
much as men yeah
so yeah i mean i mean yeah
even barring different levels of
interest and participation in resistance
training yeah that that critique breaks
down just in in the real world given how
recruitment for most of these studies
works in the first place
um
but yeah so uh to to take that criticism
seriously which i'll note not doing
after the fact
what i'm about to tell you this is in
the [ __ ] article and you would know
this if you read it uh so
i i was interested in okay uh
how would things look
if participation in research
did scale with interest in resistance
training
and so i found a paper
that was a systematic review
it doesn't call itself a systematic
review but but it was
um but it was looking at uh within
countries that have data on this
what proportion of the adult populations
um
of the male and female adult populations
meet guidelines like meet government
guidelines for partic for adequate
participation
in resistance training and general
muscle strengthening activities
and so it varies country to country but
the
the overall picture you get
is that
the of the population of people who who
do meet government's resistance training
guidelines
about 40 of them are women and about 60
percent are men
so you know the the current proportion
in research 75 male subjects 25 female
subjects even if your a priori
assumption is that we shouldn't be
aiming for 50 50 we should be aiming for
proportions that match participation in
the general population then we should
still be shooting for about 60 40 which
is a long way from 75.25
um
so yeah that that is uh that is what i
found
and like i said my my biggest uh my
biggest takeaway is just that way more
research should use mix x cohorts um
like it it come it
very rarely comes with downsides and it
does come with with pretty clear upsides
and one of the things that uh is also
worth mentioning that
i should have covered in the article but
i didn't
is i i think the article may give the
impression
that
the current state of things is fine
actually because when you look at the
forest plots confidence intervals
overlap most of the time research on
males
usually generalizes pretty well to
females so
you know
why does this matter in the first place
why should we want more uh female
participants in these studies
and so i i did do a poor job making this
clear in the article but i think one of
the primary reasons
is that there is a difference between
these two things don't seem to be
super different and these two things are
exactly the same like those are two very
different statements two very different
sentiments and at this point
uh i i suspect there are
true sex differences that do exist
that we currently don't have the
statistical power to detect
because
essentially we don't have enough
research to to adequately estimate sex
specific effect estimates so you know uh
just
just to to give an example of that um
you know let's say
there's uh
so a a great example of this is research
on training volume so there are
a ton of studies with exclusively male
subjects that look at the dose response
relationship between training volume and
muscle hypertrophy
and uh
there are
very i think there are only one or two
studies on female cohorts looking at the
same thing
and so when you look at those two bodies
of literature they generally find the
same thing that to a point higher
training volumes tend to result in more
muscle growth but
uh there's so little there's so little
research on female subjects we're
nowhere close to being able to sketch
what the dose response relationship for
female subjects might look like like we
can
we can start to do a decent job of that
with male subjects because there's
enough research but we just have no
[ __ ] idea what that dose response
curve for female subjects looks like
and so it could be very similar but not
identical like you know
like let's just assume that the ideal
level of training volume on average for
men is say 15 sets a week uh you know it
could be
uh 18 sets a week 20 sets a week for
women like i don't know if that's the
case but it could be but the thing is
like you're not going to have enough
statistical power to estimate that with
enough precision to know that those like
that that three to five set difference
is a true difference rather than just
you know a
a single estimate from a single study
that needs confirmation so
you know there there very well probably
are
some differences that that exist
that
we simply can't know about because
there's not enough
research on female subjects
to estimate with any reasonable amount
of precision
how much those effect estimates differ
um
so yeah like in general
this stuff seems to like most research
in our field seems to generalize between
the sexes pretty well
um
but it probably doesn't generalize
perfectly
and there's
currently no way to know
what areas of research male and female
lifters are like
very very similar virtually identical
and what areas of research
maybe there is a
trivial to moderate difference like in
in the cohen's d family like uh effect
size differences in the 0.1 to 0.5 range
like we don't have enough statistical
power to know if if
differences of that magnitude which are
are non-zero differences not night and
day differences but differences that are
probably large enough to actually make a
difference in terms of training
recommendations
we we simply don't have the data
to know
if differences of that magnitude exist
and if so
what areas of research those differences
exist in and and we need more research
on female subjects to
be able to estimate that with with
adequate precision to uncover those
differences
so boiling this down to uh kind of
summary bullet points here
basically
you did a meta-analysis or a survey of
meta-analyses on this topic you found
that
uh
female participants are currently
underrepresented in the research very
underrepresented very underrepresented
and it seems to be trending the wrong
direction getting worse over time
correct
current indicators suggest that there is
not a massive
you know aggregated night and day
difference to suggest that
no male findings will generalize to
female participants however well i
wouldn't even say that i i would say
we can be pretty confident that they
generalize quite well most of the time
but we can't be confident that they
generalize perfectly that there's like a
one-to-one relationship and we need more
female research this is important
because it's going to allow us to
determine where some of those small to
moderate size sex differences are that
actually could be acted upon in terms of
programming nutrition etc yeah
all right good stuff
um so are you comfortable pushing your
tech support segment or would you like
to get that in because we're like at an
hour yeah we can push it okay cool
because i i do want to briefly cover hit
high intensity interval training and
then we'll wrap up the episode sounds
good so i've been teasing this uh
coach's corner segment on hit for a long
time it's going to be very brief and to
the point
um but basically a few episodes ago a
couple maybe i i mentioned that there's
this kind of pervasive
um misconception that in order to do
high intensity interval training it has
to be maximal intensity you know i i've
seen people literally saying if you're
doing hit your work intervals cannot be
more than 30 seconds by definition
when you finish each sprint you should
feel like you're about to puke and if
you can do a hit session that's over 15
minutes you're not doing hit anymore uh
so those are common perspectives they
they simply
are not compatible with
the way high high-intensity interval
training is defined in the literature
and not compatible with how
high-intensity interval training is
studied in the literature so what's
really funny about that is some of these
same individuals who are putting out
content that reinforces this
misconception
when when you ask them to describe hit
they give you that definition and then
when you say well what's so good about
hit anyway they tell you about results
from completely different interventions
that don't meet their definition for hit
which is a little bit ironic but anyway
you can kind of generally break down
cardio into four different categories
you've got
low intensity steady state
and so that's usually you're going to
find that your heart rate is somewhere
between 50 to 69 percent of max heart
rate and you can get into all sorts of
discussions about the best way to
determine max heart rate i suppose
they're interesting discussions if
you're into it but there's a bunch of
different equations or you could just
test it you know do a maximal aerobic
test but anyway 50 to 69
you're usually going to call that low
intensity cardio and that's usually
going to be done steady state because
frankly there's not much of a need to
have
rest intervals when you're keeping
intensity that low
moderate intensity steady state usually
is going to be around 70 to 84
of maximum heart rate
theoretically you could do a steady
state bout at a much higher intensity
but it's going to be a relatively
inefficient way to do exercise because
you're going to do one go
and really tire out and and that's going
to be the end of your workout so usually
with moderate intensity
state exercise
it's going to be more of a prolonged
exercise session so you can really get
a decent volume of work in
now
high intensity interval training usually
you're going to see work bouts that are
at least 85 percent of max heart rate
and you're gonna see uh you know kind of
switching back and forth between work
intervals which are the high intensity
intervals and then rest intervals which
either involve low intensity exercise or
just passive rest right so
uh you you might do a sprint on a
bicycle and and as your work interval
and then during the rest period just
kind of pedal uh very lightly and just
kind of recover or you might take your
feet off the pedals altogether it's kind
of up to your preference uh
a cautionary note it can be very jarring
to do super high intense sprints with
passive rest periods that are short
sometimes it's very nice to have some
active recovery to kind of get some of
those metabolites circulating um so
sometimes people assume that the uh the
passive rest rather than the low
activity rest is going to be easier
sometimes it can be very nauseating if
you're doing really intense intervals
yeah um now that brings me to the final
one which is sprint interval training
and this is the
the kind of sub type of high intensity
interval training that a lot of people
think is the only type of high-intensity
interval training this is where you are
doing maximal intensity
work intervals so the work interval will
be a sprint at the highest attainable
intensity
and then you're going to have low
intensity periods as well with active or
passive recovery so sprint interval
training is a lot like back in the day
when bodybuilders like
2012 2013 got really into modified wind
gates as a
cardio modality
and what they would do
is like a 15 or a 30 second sprint on
the bike
and then you know a minute or 90 seconds
or two minutes of rest and just kind of
repeat through these extremely high
intensity maximal intensity sprints on
the bike so that is sprint interval
training which could be viewed as a sub
type of high intensity interval training
but what's really interesting is a lot
of the common hit protocols in the
literature
they actually involve four minute work
bouts which a lot of people i think
would assume doesn't even meet the
criteria for high intensity interval
training and it doesn't just meet the
criteria it's one of the most common
protocols you see in the literature so a
really common protocol is four minutes
of work you know aiming to get above 85
percent of max heart rate and then four
minutes of uh you know either active or
passive rest usually it's going to be
active rest when you have a four minute
uh
or you know it's usually three or four
minutes for for the rest interval so
usually people will do four rounds of
that so it'll be four four minute work
intervals and then between those you
have three or four minutes of active
rest but there are also a variety of
different protocols that involve
one minute work intervals two minute
three minute four minute and some as
short as you know 30 seconds and you'll
see sprint interval
training where you see
really really rapid sprints we're
talking 6 10 15 seconds long
uh of just super high intensity effort
so the span of what you could generally
call either
sprint interval trend interval training
or high intensity interval training
we're talking about sprints from uh you
know six seconds long up to work
intervals that are four minutes long um
and usually uh you know generally
speaking if i'm doing a hit or a sit
workout i try to make the total duration
of the session somewhere between 15 and
25 minutes if you're doing that and
you've got a sensible
work to what to rest ratio you know
between your two intervals that's
probably going to put you in a spot
where you're able to get enough
you know total work in enough total
volume to feel like you got a nice
session but you don't want to go
overboard with high intensity interval
training so for me personally uh you
know if i'm doing high intensity
interval training i try to do 15 to 25
total minutes and i try to keep my work
to rest ratio
somewhere around one to one so my my
favorite protocol by far is one minute
of very high intensity one minute of uh
active rest
and i'll do 10 rounds of that so it ends
up being about 19 20 minutes that's kind
of right in the sweet spot one to one
ratio work to rest if i'm doing sprint
interval training again i try to keep it
to 15 to 25 minutes but usually because
it is maximal intensity you see that the
work to rest ratio actually goes down
so instead of being one part work and
one part rest usually it's one to three
or even one to eight when you start to
see really short sprints um but yeah so
somewhere in that ballpark of one to
three to
one to eight for your work to rest ratio
uh of course all of those sprints
whether it's going to be 6 seconds or 15
or 30 seconds usually that's kind of the
range you don't see a lot of sprint
interval training with uh durations that
are too high above 30 seconds maybe a
minute but that's pretty much where it
where it kind of caps uh but yeah so you
want to make sure that you're you're
getting um a proper work to rest ratio
keeping your total duration i would
start out in the 15 to 25 minute range
and there are a lot of different ways to
incorporate uh you know high intensity
interval training even if you don't like
the super intense sprint type workouts
so this is something that's very
accessible i i'm linking a paper in the
show notes
that specifically is looking at high
intensity interval training
for for clinical populations
and so um i forget exactly i think
they're looking at yeah they're looking
at the health benefits and care related
to cardiac diseases so like i i
kind of dislike when people
put out the narrative that high
intensity interval training is only for
elite high level athletes because you
know high intensity interval training
can yield some really important health
benefits that could help out a lot of
clinical populations who should be able
to incorporate this type of exercise as
long as they are at uh you know an
appropriate health and fitness level so
you don't want to just go straight in
from fully sedentary with a clinical
condition to sprint interval training
without some kind of medical clearance
you want to make sure that you're
generally prepared for that type of
exercise but i'll link a paper in the
show notes that talks a little bit about
uh the readiness to take on this type of
high intensity stuff but you'll also
find uh for clinical populations that
some of these high intensity interval
training protocols they start with with
really modest work intervals because
it's all about building up
that kind of physiological base for the
higher intensity work so
it's still high intensity in a relative
perspective but not yet in an absolute
perspective because they have to build
up that base of cardiorespiratory
endurance so it should be a very
accessible type of exercise and even if
you don't hit that that you know
definition criteria of 85 percent of max
heart rate uh you can still incorporate
intervals when you're just getting into
cardio so like for example um you know i
just started paddle boarding and you
know you're using muscles you're not
used to using there's a lot of balance
involved it would be totally uh
understandable to say okay i want to try
to get a workout in maybe i'll do two
minutes of hard paddling and then i'll
coast for a little bit and two minutes
of hard paddling is my heart rate going
to get to 85 percent probably not but
it's still kind of an approach to
interval type exercise
and a very suitable way to apply it now
one thing that's really interesting is
we're talking about research questions
that are
just kind of not fully understood yet
and one of the really interesting things
that was observed when high intensity
interval training was was really
uh embraced by natural bodybuilding
everybody noticed like damn this sucks
like people were doing it during prep as
a cardio application uh just to kind of
burn some calories and card high
intensity especially sprint intensity
type work uh like like maximal sprint
type exercise the the
sprint interval training application
it can really take it out of you and
there were a lot of people doing this
during bodybuilding contest prep and
they just could not recover for in time
for their resistance training sessions
the total workload they just felt like
they got hit by a truck i mean it was
just really brutal
and and so that's something to keep in
mind if you're thinking about
incorporating high intensity interval
training or
you know sprint interval training you
want to try to balance out that general
burden on recovery that uh is very
different than going out for a nice
20-minute jog you know
you you can use it as a tool to get
really nice adaptations for
cardiorespiratory fitness level
you can burn a ton of calories doing it
but you want to factor in that recovery
burden that you're introducing which
does seem to be a little bit
disproportionate
and what i mean by that is there was a
study by o'leary and colleagues that i'm
going to link in the show notes um
what they found was that um
by doing uh
higher intensity effort um that that
specifically
was you know well above the anaerobic
threshold or the lactate threshold and
was uh creating a great deal of
metabolic stress during the exercise
bout they did find some indications that
it led to a disproportionate increase in
both peripheral and central fatigue uh
measured you know right after the bout
and so
what's really frustrating is we don't
have a lot of great research looking at
i would say a more ecologically valid uh
model
for typical training because a lot of
times what we're interested in is okay i
did a really high intensity interval
session on monday can i hit legs on
tuesday can i hit legs on wednesday
should i wait till thursday yeah or if i
put in you know two of these interval
sessions on top of my resistance
training is that going to be it am i
going to just totally overload my
ability to recover effectively
throughout the week so there's not a lot
of
ecologically valid applied research that
helps us make those types of decisions
for programming so hit is really tough
because anecdotally it does seem to to
introduce a very substantial recovery
burden there is some experimental
research with low ecological validity
indicating uh or kind of confirming at
least glimpses of why that might be the
case um but yeah so if you're going to
incorporate
this high-intensity interval training i
do think it's worth noting
that there are a couple studies
uh indicating that for up to 48 hours
after a session you do sometimes see
decrements in things like um
you know maximal voluntary contraction
of the muscles that were being used
sometimes 48 hours post you'll still see
elevations in things like creatine
kinase like
biomarkers of muscle damage uh you'll
still see some some delayed onset muscle
soreness at that 48 hour time point uh
and this is even in people who are
doing uh sports specific sprint training
in the sport that they compete in so
it's not like an untrained person who
you know touches a weight or does an
unaccustomed type of exercise and
they're sore for three days we're
talking about athletes doing sport
specific sprint training and still
having some muscle damage and soreness
and decrements and muscle force
you know 48 hours after the bout so you
basically want to keep that in mind i
wish that i could give you a huge volume
of research that tells you exactly how
to incorporate that throughout the week
a little bit of it is going to be guess
and check but it's something to keep in
mind if you start incorporating more
high-intensity exercise
but yeah i think that's pretty much all
i wanted to cover here
i do think it's important to acknowledge
if you look at
the body comp research for for cardio
whether we're talking fat loss or the
small gains in lean mass that tend to
occur when untrained people take up a
cardio modality
um
the body comp changes for steady state
versus interval training seem very
similar so it's not like one is way
better than the other when you look at
the concurrent training literature
also it seems to indicate that they're
generally pretty similar in terms of
their potential to uh introduce any type
of interference effect now there are
mixed findings in that area you
absolutely will find paper saying
actually high-intensity interval
training is better
you will find some papers where people
hint at the idea that maybe it's even
worse in terms of concurrent training
and interference effects
we've talked about the interference
effect ad nauseam so probably no reason
to
go back into detail and hit that topic
hard if you go back in the archives
we've talked about it many times um but
but there is no whether you're looking
at independent effects on body
composition or
uh you know trying to circumvent any
potential interference effect
there's really not clear evidence to say
that interval training versus steady
state that one is better or worse than
the other these are different tools that
can be incorporated
and when it comes to cardio you got to
find something that fits your
preferences and can be incorporated into
your weekly training schedule without
negatively impacting the other things
you like to do in many cases you should
be able to do that with steady state
cardio or interval training and like i
said there are a ton of ways to do
interval training
sounds good
all right i've got uh just two more
quick notes before before the to play us
out segment sure so the the first one uh
i i meant to mention this in my previous
segment about my article uh and i forgot
to so um
one very important thing to note
is that i think that it may be
tempting to to listen to everything that
i had to say about female subjects being
underrepresented in the research
and
uh
ascribe negative motives to the
researchers doing that research um
like i i
saw the statement several times like oh
i didn't realize that exercise science
researchers were this sexist um
and
i understand where that sentiment's
coming from i think that that's
i wouldn't feel comfortable
uh ascribing that motive to people
i think what's what's much more
reasonable or
much more likely at least
is that uh until
i mean like even up to the present day
there's
some amount of
of logistical concern with having mixed
sex cohorts or just with with studying
female lifters in the first place so
there's
concerns that uh hormonal contraception
contraceptive usage could have a notable
impact on results that male and female
subjects will have notably different
results to a particular intervention or
that testing at different points in the
menstrual cycle for your female subjects
could add a lot of noise to your data
and all of those things are things
researchers want to avoid um
you know just because like if you're if
you're adding noise you need to have a
larger effect to be able to detect the
signal you're trying to detect and so
there's concern that like a lot of the
research in our field is kind of
underpowered in the first place that
might just increase the risk of false
negatives you know just harder to get
clear results um
like so i think that's where a lot of of
trepidation comes from
um
and i think that now we can we can more
confidently say
that those are
uh understandable concerns for people to
have had
but based on research that has
progressed over the last 20 30 years uh
it doesn't like those seem to be
very understandable concerns that people
had that they probably don't need to
have anymore
so there there have been some metas
published in the last couple of years
looking at how performance fluctuations
across the menstrual cycle look they
tend to be pretty small for most
measures of performance uh there's now a
fair bit of research looking at how
contraceptives affect exercise
performance exercise adaptations long
story short
they don't really seem to have a major
difference like they don't seem to make
a major difference most of the time and
like i mentioned uh you know
now we can look across you know close to
40 areas of research look to see
whether studies on male and female
cohorts are frequently coming to very
different conclusions they don't seem to
be
so it seems like you know you can
probably use mixed sex cohorts
not really have to worry that much about
added logistical hurdles not have to
worry about that much additional noise
in your data set easier time recruiting
uh more generalizable results a lot you
know a lot of upsides very few downsides
but you know it's only become recently
like it's only been pretty recent that
we can now
know with a pretty high degree of
confidence that there are pretty small
downsides so i think that's where a lot
of it just came from historically um you
know there there was the perception that
it was basically just easier to study
male subjects than female subjects or
mixed sex cohorts just just fewer
potential confounders in play
and
i think it's uh it would be very fair to
discuss whether that is a good reason
for primarily 65 of the time studying
male-only cohorts um but you know
at worst i think you could say maybe
it's laziness uh
more charitably you could say that it's
you know logistical concerns publisher
parish environment if you can crank out
a few more papers a little bit faster
with male subjects instead of having to
go jump through some more logistical
hoops you know maybe it's just the
easier approach um
and
i wouldn't
necessarily count
those motives as sexism per se uh so i
think it's i think it's more that stuff
than you know people just like
intentionally not wanting to study
female cohorts yeah and i i can say i've
been involved in many many many many
discussions planning studies yeah and
one thing
that is really frustrating uh is that
even if you're working with a group of
very competent researchers who
understand all of those kind of updated
perspectives uh based on research that's
happened over the last you know 20 30
years
there is still a
i think a really pervasive expectation
that
your reviewers for your paper will not
understand that so i think a lot of
researchers say i know that oral
contraceptives are not going to ruin my
study i know that this is completely
viable to be a mixed sex sample for this
study however
i think at least one of my potential
reviewers
will hold that against me and for that
reason i won't even try
uh and i like you said publisher parish
a lot of people are thinking not just
how do i answer this question but how do
i answer this question and get it
published in the
uh most seamless way possible the least
friction the least number of battles and
quibbles with reviewers yeah because if
you have to resubmit to four journals
before someone takes it like that's
that's just wasted time that you could
be spending any number of other like you
could be doing any other number of
productive things right yeah so a lot of
time a lot of effort yeah and so a lot
of people will make this decision even
though they know better but they think i
don't think everyone else knows better
yeah and i think a reviewer is going to
give me a hard time and to them i would
uh
say there was a phrase that one of my
old stat professors used to use uh he he
was a really funny guy very snarky and
cynical but uh he used to always say
because like some people would do the
same thing in stats they would say i
have a very nuanced sophisticated way to
approach this but the reviewers aren't
going to get it so i'm going to use a
simpler procedure that is worse
objectively worse for this question and
he would say
give the reviewers a chance to
disappoint you
and they probably will but give them the
opportunity yeah and you might be
surprised and find that they actually
don't disappoint you yeah so yeah i just
wanted to make sure i got this out like
i wanted to make sure i got that out
here um
you know i i wouldn't want someone to
come away from the segment
either thinking that just all exercise
science researchers are massively sexist
or
thinking that i think that exercise
science researchers are massively sexist
i i think that there are
maybe not the best conceivable reasons
for things to currently be the way they
are but there there are reasons that are
at least understandable and not just
purely motivated by sexism so that
that's one thing i wanted to to note the
other thing i wanted to note just for
people in the facebook group and
subreddit uh i posted threads uh asking
for for questions for a q a segment i
did that before i realized how much
content we already had on this outline
but those questions will not go to waste
um
a thing coming up that does not affect
you guys at all but does affect us is uh
we're currently recording on mondays
we're going to move to a friday
recording schedule uh
maybe next week maybe a couple weeks
from now regardless but there's going to
be a week where we're recording two
episodes in a calendar week
and at least one of those episodes i can
guarantee you will be very q a heavy um
so those those questions will not go to
waste we will address them absolutely
all right let's wrap it up here uh to
play us out we both have some segments
uh i'm gonna start out with a music
recommendation
uh the black keys a well-known band um
my buddy luke got me into the loop
got me into the black keys
um probably like 2007
and then we went to lollapalooza in 2008
the big music festival in chicago
and back in 2008 the black keys were not
a household name so they actually went
on stage at
maybe i mean it might have been as early
as like two or three in the afternoon uh
but they certainly were not a headliner
uh and they were incredible and one of
the things that really struck me about
about their live set back in that 0708
time range
is
very very blues heavy i mean you you
still get glimpses in some of their more
uh recent work but back then the the the
blues influence would hit you over the
head especially when they would play
live and kind of riff off of their their
studio uh albums so um
my music recommendation of course is to
check out the black keys they're great
they're from they're they're buckeyes
like me they're from ohio akron
specifically rubber capital of the world
or so they claim hell yeah uh
but uh so black black keys great band
great ohio folks to support but also
i would encourage people to
use the black keys as a gateway to a
kind of sub genre of music which is
called hill country blues so this is um
a very
um
yeah it's a specific subtype of the
blues like i said it's called hill
country blues mostly associated with
uh
northern mississippi and it's a very
rich tradition of blues music
i'll link the wikipedia in the show
notes but it kind of gives you an idea
of what what it's like but
a little quote from the wikipedia
characterized by a strong emphasis on
rhythm and percussion steady guitar
riffs few chord changes unconventional
song structures and heavy emphasis on
the groove which has been characterized
as the hypnotic boogie so that that
should be enough to get you interested
uh
unconventional song structures like i
said i i like a lot of uh unconventional
kind of complexity in my song so i i
think that's why i'm so drawn to it but
a couple great musicians uh from this
hill country blues tradition junior
kimbrough and r.l burnside are
very well known within this particular
genre and cedric burnside who is the
grandson of r.l burnside uh
and i think cedric's father might have
been
there it's uh there's some relation
between cedric burnside and junior
kimbrough's drummer i believe but it's
it's this really like localized regional
approach to blues music uh and everybody
played with ever with each other uh you
know there's a lot of collaboration
and yeah it's it's just really good
really authentic blues and the fun thing
is when you start reading into their uh
biographical content about all these
musicians they are all like
mythical people like like the way that
they approach music and life like it was
just such a like when you read into some
of these big characters within the genre
they're just like larger than life
personalities um so yeah it's a a very
uh rich
blues tradition and musically it's just
excellent so check it out very nice
i i have a far more basic uh
media recommendation probably not quite
as cultured
but my wife and i uh are currently
playing through the most recent entry
into the pokemon canon pokemon legends
arceus
and i gotta say it's been a blast so far
if you enjoyed playing pokemon games for
for game boy when you were young
and at some point you just kind of
burned out you're like okay i've played
the same game 10 times at this point
it's all the same you pick a starter you
beat some gem leaders you beat the elite
four
throw the master ball at a legendary
pokemon and boom you're done um you know
if you got kind of tired of that formula
uh pokemon legends arceus still uh
contains the core pokemon dna
while
being a very welcome change of pace
so um
it takes place like hundreds or
thousands of years before
the main pokemon story when people are
just coming in contact with and learning
about pokemon initially and so you're
playing as uh essentially a researcher
who's going around and and trying to
catch and study the pokemon um you know
there's not like the same gym leader
type structure and
i would say the moment-to-moment
gameplay is far more engaging because
it's uh not like a fully open world but
it's kind of like a semi-open world
concept like you go to particular areas
you can move around freely
and instead of just a pokemon jumping
out at you from the wild grass uh you
can see them
like they're they're all there they're
walking around kind of like the big kind
of central hub area and sword and shield
but they'll actually like attack your
character so you know you're not just
walking around in tall grass waiting to
be attacked like for for grinding for
levels um you know you're you're like
actively trying to avoid pokemon who are
trying to attack you the player not just
like your pokemon uh and also like when
you're trying to catch certain ones like
some are skittish and so you have to
sneak up on them so there's a bit of a
stealth element um you know you you have
to dodge attacks with a with a dodge
like roll mechanic that's very similar
to dark souls which i find very funny um
but yeah it's uh it's it's a fun game
like there there's definitely some
there there are some ways that it
doesn't quite work uh which which makes
sense like it's a it's a relatively
large departure from
a
series of games that had been very
formulaic for for a long time so it's
it's not perfectly polished but if you
have ever enjoyed a pokemon game i i
think it's worth checking out it's it's
a lot of fun
all right good stuff i don't want to
brag but back in the day on the game boy
version of pokemon
um
i i had a pretty special lineup i i
really cleaned up so uh i don't know if
i'm gonna give this one a try but
hopefully some people will good deal
all right uh that does it for this
episode as always thank you for
listening and we'll be back next week
with another
thank you for listening to the stronger
by science podcast
if you enjoyed the podcast be sure to
sign up for our free newsletter to get
concise breakdowns of relevant research
as well as 28 free training programs for
all skill levels and all schedules
we hate spam just as much as you do so
we'll only email you when we have
something really interesting to share
with you
you can sign up for the free newsletter
at strongerbyscience.com
newsletter or just go to the stronger by
science homepage and click the free
programs button at the top
if you want to join in on the stronger
by science podcast conversation be sure
to check out our facebook group and our
subreddit the links for both are
provided in the description of today's
episode
finally please remember that we are not
medical doctors or registered dietitians
so before you make any changes to your
exercise or nutrition habits be sure to
check with a qualified health care
professional
once again thank you for listening and
we will be back soon with another
episode of the stronger by science
podcast
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
you